[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le journal
de tv 78 nous sommes le mercredi 18
septembre voici les titres de cette
édition
sensibilisés à la lutte contre le sida
et interpellé les pouvoirs publics
depuis le 3 septembre jérémy chalon
réalise un périple de 1600 km en france
il reconstitue un ruban rouge en
traversant les villes qui souhaitent
s'engager étape ce soir dans les
yvelines avec mon autre sensibilisation
celle au cancer de la tête et du cou une
campagne a été lancée cette semaine pour
informer sur ces maladies aux symptômes
vous le verrez plutôt banal stéphanie
lemerle secrétaire adjointe de corazo
est notre invité et puis elle a 13 ans
et est originaire de maurepas nour
participe à l'émission de télé-crochet
deux vice kid diffusé ce vendredi à la
jeune chanteuse a été sélectionné parmi
vingt mille vidéos reçues par la
production
cette information pour commencer
rapportés par nos confrères d'europe 1
emmanuel macron aurait validé le projet
de fusion entre les yvelines et les
hauts-de-seine ce rapprochement est
voulue pour rappel par les deux
départements depuis 2016 un feu vert qui
auraient été données par le président de
la république au printemps contacté par
notre rédaction le ministère de la
cohésion des territoires dément
toutefois l'information tout comme
l'elysée une rencontre a bien eu lieu
avec les présidents des deux
collectivités les discussions sont elles
toujours en cours est la décision finale
sera prise effectivement par le
président de la république ait démenti
également du côté du département des
hauts-de-seine celui des yvelines enfin
elle ne souhaite pas à commenter cette
information
[Musique]
interpellé les pouvoirs publics et
demandé à la france de retrouver son
rôle de leader dans la lutte contre le
sida à l'initiative du à crips ile de
france et de ses partenaires jérémy
chalon parcours en ce moment à la france
et ce depuis à début septembre il
réalise une boucle en traversant est les
villes qui s'engagent dans la lutte
contre le sida jérémy qui est avec nous
en direct dans ce journal bonsoir
bonsoir
alors vous fait étape ce soir et
vêtements dans les yvelines comment se
déroule cette initiative depuis vos
débuts vous êtes passé notamment par
bordeaux vous êtes parti bordeaux vous
êtes passé par orléans reims lille ou
encore au havre qu'elle accueille
avez vous reçu eh bien écoutez ça se
passe super bien c'est assez assez assez
sympa en fait de voir toute l'énergie
qui se dégage en fait ceux de ce
parcours et on a un super accueil de la
part des citoyens des élus des
associations n'ont pour l'instant
pour l'instant tout va bien mais on voit
cette carte s'afficher avec votre
parcours aussi celui qui vous reste à
faire alors l'un des objectifs c'est que
la france retrouve son rôle de leader en
augmentant sa contribution au fonds
mondial de lutte contre le sida
ça veut dire que sa participation
aujourd'hui elle est en recul par
rapport à ce qu'est ce qui te faisait
avant non sa participation elle est en
stagnation aujourd'hui la france donne
pour le fonds mondial 360 millions de
dollars par an sur trois ans est en fait
le lit d'autres pays qui ont augmenté
leurs dotations notamment l'allemagne le
royaume uni le royaume-uni le japon et
l'italie et on voudrait puisque c'est un
des moyens pour arriver à la fin du sida
que la france augmente sa dotation au
fonds mondial de lutte contre le sida la
tuberculose et le paludisme
pourquoi faire étape ce soir à évêques
membres les yvelines alors l'étape avec
nous en fait elle s'est décidée parce
qu'on a été sollicité par la merde avec
moi qui avais envie de
de s'intégrer dans ce parcours et de
signer l'appel de la boucle du ruban
rouge qui a un appel collectif
interassociatif puisqu'à le crips île de
france mais aussi nos partenaires aident
sidaction solidarité sida sida info
service élus locaux contre le sida est
donc cet appel
il est destiné à interpeller le
président de la république pour qu' il
puisse augmenter la dotation fonds
mondial donc la mer des vêtements on
nous a demandé si on voulait faire étape
ici et on est ravi d'être ici et la
suite du parcours pour vous alors là il
ya une grosse grosse partie en
ile-de-france a pendant quinze jours en
fait je vais parcourir différentes
villes notamment demain puisqu'on a le
soutien du conseil régional d'île de
france
on sera reçu par le conseil régional et
notamment la présidente valérie pécresse
on va avoir aussi des étapes dans des
villes comme pantin montreuil coubon
gonesse
evry créteil qu'on veut voir
boulogne et le 21 donc samedi prochain
on organise une grande manifestation sur
la place de l'hôtel de ville qui aura
lieu dans l'après midi avec le collectif
interassociatif et on vous souhaite une
bonne suite de parcours merci à vous
gérez michalon merci aussi à mathilde
demi pour les moyens techniques on
retrouvera d'ailleurs un reportage sur
cette initiative dans notre journal de
demain jeudi
leurs symptômes sont plutôt banal mais
conduisent malheureusement à un
dépistage tardif qui réduit
considérablement les chances de guérison
prenons le cancer à la gorge la campagne
lancée pour sensibiliser au cancer de la
tête et du cou est responsable de cinq
mille décès par an en france est la
quatrième cause de mortalité par cancer
cette campagne a été lancée par
plusieurs acteurs la société française
de cardiologie à cervico faciale et
l'association de patients corazo bonsoir
stéphanie lemerle
vous êtes la secrétaire adjointe de
corazo pourquoi lancer c'est que cette
campagne quels sont les objectifs à
j'aime les filles de chaque campagne
c'est de faire connaître l'équipe de
caen cher puisque les camps fier aux
relations très peu connu et du fait qu
sion peu connu il ya eu souvent les
gérants de diagnostic
ils vont chercher à gonfler chaque
campagne donc pour faire connaître
davantage ce type de cancer il ya
quatorze mille nouveaux cas qui sont
détectés chaque année en france
ça veut dire que c'est un type de cancer
qui est qui est fréquent relativement
fréquents et ce qui est gênant sur les
symptômes qui peuvent paraître
effectivement banias et qui passe au
travers et le diagnostic précoce on va
parler de ces symptômes dans un instant
c'est aussi les types de cancers qui
peuvent toucher plusieurs zones du corps
voilà c'est assez large ces cancers
finalement de la tête et du cou oui
c'est ce qu'on appelle en fait la partie
du coup jusque sous les yeux en fait les
yeux et c'est heureux ne font pas partie
du camp shira où l'on vous a des gosses
ticket un cancer de la langue à
versailles ce sont les chiens au centre
hôpital mignot il était suspecté en
radiothérapie et aussi sur versailles
aurait peut-être des symptômes qui vous
ont alerté justement ces symptômes on le
disait qu'ils peuvent paraître plutôt
banal quels sont-ils quels symptômes
finalement
nous alerter c'est par elle même de ce
que j'ai pu avantage pour huit
exactement chasse ayant un mouvement qui
dure depuis plusieurs semaines c'est ya
une chute et avaié il faut écouter a
parié il ya il faut consulter
il faut consulter aussi quand vous avez
un gars que je suis papa depuis un
moment
ils prennent de nier en congrès cliquez
sur un fake et qui ne paraît pas qu'ils
ne disparaissent pas voilà tous types de
shenzhen bayane qui s'est en fait que
plus de trois semaines puisque c'est des
symptômes qu'on peut rencontrer dans la
vie tous les jours en fait le moment on
doit s'alerter c'est s'il dure dans le
temps en temps il faut consulter info
pas venir par ailleurs non plus mais je
t'ai bien qu'ils avaient consulté
consultant auprès de son médecin
généraliste dans un paysage un premier
temps et en fonction des symptômes
biomérieux a géré prendre justement qu'à
moi mon médecin genia riche marange
everio url qui au bout de deux
consultations et a touché j'ai jamin et
s'est rendu compte qu effectivement mais
chantôme bannu et et ayez un français
justement sur le dépistage je disais
tout à l'heure cinq mille décès par an
en france causée par ces cancers de la
tête et du cou on imagine que le
dépistage et est très important plus on
dépiste tôt ce cancer plus il ya de
chances de guérison tarifaire visite des
régions c'est sur les traitements et
julien de traitement qui gagnait
beaucoup si la chirurgie
sauf que plus la tumeur est grosse plus
la chirurgie est importante voire des
fois impossible
outrage invalidante il dans mon cas et
une mort qui a vu plus tôt je ne paye
pas et on ne rappelait pas enlever
j'aurais pu parler correctement et mieux
manger et c'est donc ce dépistage ou et
dans votre cas pas été alors a été fait
assez tôt mais finalement pas ouï fm
gestion des symptômes qui se voit pas
forcément et on conçoit new alerté comme
je décide de consulter peut y avoir
interrompu les cours puis enlevée
diagnostiqué tôt pu franchir est pris
tôt on peut opérer peut-être que
facilement donc voilà pour les symptômes
le dépistage les facteurs à risque quels
sont ils sûrs sur ce bien sûr l'équipe
de france hier est souvent connue quand
même par rapport au tabac au cabba et à
l'alcool il de mélanger c'est un facteur
à risque très important il ya aussi tout
ce qui est fumé poussière et puis encore
bien le facteur qu'on n'y a pas réussi à
trouver encore aujourd'hui par exemple
pour ma part je fume pas je ne bois pas
je suis pas où j'irai fumer et pour
finir j'ai eu un cancer
ouais et il ya des associations qui
informent sur ces cancers la vôtre un
corazo justement un dernier mot sur sur
cette association qui est une
association de patients son but c'est
vraiment d'informer et d'accompagner les
malades qui assure l'association en
france confirmant les cancers orl quand
il ya des lieux chics et on fait un peu
tout qui s'écroule et le fait d'avoir
une association référent on peut
échanger avec des patients on peut avoir
les informations il espère qu'elle
chante on peut se renseigner ces deux
faits importants
c'est une des missions primordiales de
qu'horatio c'est une association qu'à
cinq ans il ya 220 ans pour l'instant et
on a des missions très ambitieuse
vraiment de faire pas su allier mocratie
santé de faire bouger au niveau de la
qualité de vie du patient avec déjà
accueilli avec les choses les gens
l'antenne nationale
voilà un peu un peu un tas de missions
avec une grosse actualité en cette
rentrée
et cette campagne prenons le cancer à la
gorge qui informe main sur ces cancers
de la tête et du cou une campagne lancée
notamment par votre association
stéphanie lemaire merci d'être passé sur
ce plateau et je rappelle que vous êtes
la secrétaire adjointe de corazo on peut
retrouver toutes les informations sur le
site internet site internet vous
surveille toute la clique et des vidéos
enfin et notamment une campagne vidéo
quoi ma gueule un qui a été diffusé sur
votre site internet merci d'être passé à
vous autres campagnes cette fois ci sur
le plan politique les élections
municipales en mars 2020 ce vendredi la
liste décidons ensemble à guyancourt
candidature participative pour le
scrutin dans la ville commencera à son
opération de porte à porte pour trouver
ses colistiers pour le symbole les
membres seront uniquement aux portes
comportant le numéro 20 en référence à
l'année de l'élection
une méthode de tirage au sort expliqué
par téléphone par le conseiller
municipal olivier paréja écouter tout le
monde et les jeunes à participer
il n'y a pas de raison que le fait de
devenir une ville de lancer des projets
dans une ville soit limité à seulement
une partie des gens après chacun
s'implique à ta façon avec possibilité
mais mais tout le monde est légitime
surtout à un niveau communal des propos
recueillis par mathilde eu de mise
chaque année les français déposent en
moyenne 3,6 millions de tonnes
d'encombrants sur les trottoirs des
objets difficile à revaloriser mais qui
à qui on pourrait donner tout de même
une seconde vie à la manivelle une
recyclerie situé au mesnil saint denis à
l'atelier réparé bricoles qui est
proposé le reportage sur cette
initiative de gwenaëlle saintil
acheter je t'ai abandonné remplacer nous
sommes dans une ère où les objets ont
une durée de vie très faible et
finissent très rapidement à la poubelle
jean-paul à trouver une solution à cette
logique du tout jeter les ateliers
réparé bricole passionnés de travaux
manuels depuis tout petit il en a fait
son activité professionnelle et souhaite
transmettre sa passion le temps d'une
journée on le retrouve à la manivelle
la recyclerie du mesnil-saint-denis pour
un atelier réparation d'appareils
électroménagers et affûtage pour les
particuliers alors réparé bricole on
veut par des bricoles qui sont
insignifiants mais qui ont de la valeur
ça peut prendre pas en plein cada
sécateur qui
a été réfutée qui me briand et couple
comme une paire de ciseaux
je vais avec un juste la ville
reproduire cette tour de manuel marquez
là cet outil est prêt pour jardiner dans
des bonnes conditions de celle d'autres
registres donc à faire avant passé et
qui se soucie de chauffer il suffisait
de nettoyer le contact du thermostat
il est moche air de racheter un objet
neuf que de le réparer donc la démarche
c'est plus défi écologique et une prise
de conscience qu'on peut réparer certain
nombre d'objets je dirais soi-même et
oui tout nouvel objet fabriqué utilisent
de l'énergie pour les machines qui vont
l'assemblée et les transports qui vont
la cheminée mais ils consomment aussi
des ressources naturelles pour ces
matériaux ressources planétaires qui ne
sont pas infinies donc réparer plutôt
que jeter c'est une démarche pour moins
gaspiller pour ça venez faire un tour à
la manivelle du mesnil-saint-denis
nouvelles boutiques ouvertes il ya
quelques mois vous pourrez peut-être et
dénicher la perle rare que vous cherchez
pas je culturel la deuxième saison de la
commanderie de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
et lancé une journée festive était
organisée samedi dernier pour promouvoir
la culture bien sûr mais aussi les
autres activités proposées sur ce lieu
situé à elancourt patrick jacques de
dixmude et maxime à bolland c'est une
nouvelle saison culturelle pleine de
promesse forte de ses dix-sept mille
visiteurs l'an dernier la commanderie
s'est préparé pour une programmation
encore plus complète pour le lancement
les visiteurs ont pu découvrir des
prestations de danse en plein air des
expositions photos ou encore des
ateliers du son au tour du theremin
c'est comme beaucoup d'instruments à
cordes le violon etc
il ya une main qui se charge de
l'émission du sont donc le volume du son
l'intensité sonore et une main qui se
chargent la hauteur donc typiquement
c'est la main gauche d'un violoniste ou
d'un violoncelliste là chez nous c'est
la main droite
l'antenne verticale du terrain
et donc le but c'est évidemment d'avoir
une très bonne coordination entre dès
demain pour que les notes va clairement
séparés et expressive la première saison
à la commanderie tourné en grande partie
autour de la culture
cette année ce lieu va s'ouvrir
également à d'autres perspectives
la culture reste quand même le socle ou
aujourd'hui on doit être plus risible in
her an douar une multiplicité de stimuli
est capable de d'accompagner les gens à
l'ailé les ouvrir sur sur sur ce monde
très très multiples donc voilà c'est le
but bien entendu au travers de 50 entre
la commanderie
nous notre objectif c'est que ce soit un
lieu de vie pas seulement estampillé
culture mais que les gens aient envie
d'y venir
envie de découvrir et c'est pour ça que
nous avons une programmation bien
évidemment culturelle dans les quatre
missions mais aussi de projets tels que
noël décalé au cinéma de plein air ou
voilà que nous tentons de mettre en
place pour que tout le monde puisse
s'approprier la commanderie à l'occasion
des journées du patrimoine de nombreuses
activités sont à retrouver la
commanderie proposera notamment un jeu
de piste samedi 21 et dimanche 22
septembre
comme tous les mercredis direction l'une
des salles de cinéma de notre territoire
ce soir c'est l'espace philippe noiret
aux clayes sous bois qui présente sa
programmation et c'est au micro bien sûr
de patrick jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
cette semaine dans les salles de
l'espace philippe noiret de la ville les
clayes sous bois
nous avons bien entendu les 10 ans de
noir et que vous savez déjà samedi pour
cela on organise aussi une rétrospective
des films joués par philippe noiret
comme alexandre le bienheureux cinéma
paradiso ou zazie dans le métro qui
seront jouées dans les deux semaines à
venir
nous avons aussi une grande sélection de
films comme par exemple le dernier film
d'animation de zabou breitman les
hirondelles de kaboul
nous avons également la vie scolaire
tant attendu la comédie dramatique
française et nous avons également deux
mois le dernier film de klapisch deux
protagonistes
rémy et mélanie un peu perdu dans notre
société actuelle où on est dans une
génération 2.0 elle qui cherche l'amour
sur les réseaux sociaux
lui qui perce patience a rencontré une
jeune femme lors de chemins vont se
rencontrer
peut-être sera-t-il pour un amour commun
c'est à vous de le voir je vous invite
donc à aller le voir chez nous mais
c'est quand même dingue de tomber sur
quelqu'un qui est vraiment vraiment mais
rien à dire on va parler quand 1h46
randonnée m'a dit j'ai l'impression que
ça fait des années que je te cherche l
angoisse
tu travailles pas tourné farine et
karine votre avec karine karine pdci
khaled ben d'accord alors une brune à
laver les mêlées à des boucles à
maintenant les abidjanais ont des soucis
dans sa tête
[Musique]
après les sorties en salles sortie à
littéraire un trappistes a publié cet
été sont à dernier roman panique sur les
porte-avions vous plonge dans un futur
assez proche et pour le moins
apocalyptique et ce trappistes c'est
vous rick de lavalas dernier bonsoir
merci de nous recevoir
alors vous êtes l'auteur bien sûr de
ceux à techno thriller d'anticipation
c'est comme ça que vous le définissez
pourquoi vous vous lavez techno thriller
c'est un roman contemporain
d'anticipation un peu sur l'avenir en
fonction de l'actualité
il ya des exercices de géopolitique
entre différents états des complots
mondiaux et cetera quoi donc le maître
en la matière c'était tom clancy
donc j'étais fan de ses romans et donc
j'essaye d'écrire pour le moment
peut-être pas aussi bien que lui mais
dans la même veine alors des conflits en
inde en panique sur les porte-avions qui
se déroule dans un futur finalement pas
si éloigné en 2020 avec des événements
inquiétants on peut le dire un
cataclysme qui détruit la côte ouest des
états unis et fait des millions de morts
c'est le point de départ de point de
départ aux airs en 2020 donc j'ai
imaginé que c'était bientôt est en fait
le cataclysme
c'est un état étranger qui l'a provoquée
en mettant 120 têtes nucléaires le long
de la faille de casque à dire donc le en
fait le premier tome ça s'appelle
cascadia la chute de l'amérique et dans
ce premier tome 10 ont ils vont enquêter
et retrouver le coupable avant de
d'essayer de mettre un terme à sa
dictature
dans panique sur le portable que le
premier tome un doute on voit on vient
de voir la couverture s'affiche et vous
l'avez dit c'est la suite alors il ya
une enquête qui va s'enclencher c'est sa
ville d'amiens tome c'est dans le
deuxième tome c'est plutôt un roman
d'aventurés qui mêle guerre thriller
aventure action on s'ennuie pas quoi ça
bouge beaucoup
est-ce qu'il faut lire dans l'ordre
d'abord cascadia on peut comme par magie
il faut dire qu est-ce qu il ya ça dure
sur quelques jours en fait alors centre
cascadia finalement c'est aussi fait
partie d'une série de romans vous avez
amené avec vous que ce que en fait
cascadia et panique sur les porte-avions
sont en fait les préquelles d'une
trilogie vous avez sorti aussi ces
dernières années c'est ça oui j'ai
imaginé qu'en 2000 28-29 y avait une
grosse guerre civile
éliminer 90 % des hommes donc les femmes
prennent le pouvoir et recréer un
univers matriarcale pendant une
trentaine d'années
donc on pense que c'est bien organisé
mais les hommes sont plus ou plus ou
moins esclaves de la société et ils vont
se rebeller
dans ma trilogie donc cette trilogie
pour le coup on peut la lire d'abord oui
on peut la lire d'abord et après on
verra plein de clins d'oeil dans dans
cascadia et dans panique sur le
porte-avions mais on peut aussi faire l'
inverse alors c'est ça fait 5 livres en
tout qui ont été publiés en l'espace de
trois ans à un rythme effréné
pour bah oui j'en ai profité d'être
chômage donc entre mes recherches
d'emploi donc j'en profite pour écrire
donc j'étais ingénieur dans l'industrie
donc on est habitué de travailler assez
vite
et cette passion pour l'écriture d'où
vient-elle va aller venu très jeune je
croque mon premier roman j'ai commencé à
l'écrire le lendemain où l'homme a
marché sur la lune
donc j'avais 9 ans j'ai commencé voyage
sur masson en 3000 je m'étais dit il
faut aller plus loin
donc c'est une passion voilà qui qui
vient de loin vous voyez déjà dans le
futur les récits des je dessinais aussi
beaucoup donc je faisais des bd etc
et donc mes romans c'est un peu un mix
de ça pourrait faire des films c'est
tout c'est wang fans me demande quand
est-ce qu'on sort le film
ça pourrait être l'un de vos prochains
projets pourquoi la science fiction et
vous parliez tout à l'heure d'un goût
pour tom clancy's pourquoi la science
fiction pour le convoi quand j'étais
jeune je faisais beaucoup de science
fiction j'aime bien imaginez ce qui peut
se passer dans le futur aussi donc ça
amics de faits réels et d'anticipation
sur sur le futur alors c'est des romans
qui sont disponibles soit sur commande
auprès de vous sur amazon cessé de
l'autoédition fils est autorisée oui oui
donc je fais tout par internet et donc
ils sont mis en ligne automatiquement et
sera ma zone
donc quand on n'est pas très connue
c'est hyper pratique les gens peuvent
acheter partout dans le monde quoi
donc je fais beaucoup de séances de
dédicaces pour essayer de me faire
connaître
donc les gens marchent comme je ne suis
pas connu les gens achètent souvent les
tomes 1 et après ils savent qu'ils
peuvent avoir la suite là sur internet
on a aussi les informations sur la page
facebook à votre page facebook
qui va s'afficher vous parliez des
dédicaces qu'il y en a des sédiments
dimanche occultera de plaisir le 5 le
samedi saint caprais octobre je fais le
cultura de villennes sur seine
je suis aussi des leclerc des courants
et c'est donc un peu partout de voir
toujours faire contre le territoire
les projets ce que c'est d'en écrire
d'autres ont parié au cinéma je sais pas
si c'est une blague mais peut-être que
c'est cesser dans votre tête c'est dans
un coin de votre tête de votre tête
il faudra que je prenne contact avec des
metteurs en scène où que je sois
remarqué par quoi après bon ça peut
aller vite si ça intéresse quelqu'un
mais pour l'instant je me limite à rien
en tout cas ce projet il est déjà sorti
c'est panique sur les porte-avions un
techno thriller d'anticipation qui est
d'ores et déjà disponible alors soit sur
commande toutes les informations sur la
page votre page facebook ou aussi sur le
portail amazon merci briques de laval a
verni d'être passé en plateau avant de
se quitter une jeune saint-quentinoise
qui participent à la sixième édition de
l'émission la musicale de voice kids
nour à 13 ans habite à maurepas et ce
vendredi vous pourrez découvrir sa
prestation avec les auditions à
l'aveuglent or il y est arrosé à margaux
du roi l'ont rencontrée chez elle je
prends mon vieux titres
chanson c'est un rituel que nous refait
chaque jour quand elle rentre des cours
à 13 ans cette collégienne de maurepas a
décidé de se lancer dans l'aventuré
overijse lead une émission de télé
crochet qu'elle a l'habitude de regarder
en famille il ya deux ans j'ai demandé à
maman s'il pouvait faire et ce qu'ils
aiment avait dit que c'était trop jeune
pour le faire qu'il n'avait pas encore
enfin la voix pour le faire et du coup
donc j'ai attendu un an un an je me suis
entraîné et tout et puis maintenant
après j'ai demandé à maman qu'elle
envoie une vidéo
[Musique]
et c'est quelque chose chez elle de
vital presque de chanter donc je sais
que elle en a besoin qu'elles adorent ça
depuis toute petite elle a toujours
chanté même tout bébé
nous on n'a jamais pris de cours de
chant et pourtant sa voix a fait la
différence parmi les vingt mille vidéos
reçues par la production
après avoir franchi différentes étapes
elle est sélectionnée pour les auditions
à l'aveuglé l'émission a été enregistrée
il ya un an
si au départ sa maman était sereine elle
la pression se fait de plus en plus
présente
je me suis pas trop posé de questions je
stressais pas encore trop c'est plutôt
sait même pas trop pendant le tournage
de l'émission mais c'était pousser plus
tôt après que les questions arrivent on
s'est plutôt des questions
voilà deux mamans quoi qui veut
préserver
ben voilà sa fille cas que 13 ans même
si elle fait plus et pour savoir si nous
re continue l'aventuré the voice kid
rendez vous devant votre petit écran le
vendredi 20 septembre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est la fin du set 8 journal merci de
l'avoir suivi dans un instant sur tv 78
le 7-8 société comment sauver les
urgences la question soulevée en plein
un mouvement de grève
quant à moi j'aurai le plaisir vous
retrouvez dès demain pour une nouvelle
édition d'information locale et en
direct à partir de 18h belle soirée sur
tv 78
[Musique]